both of them were warming up for
today's match with games and puzzles on
chess.com so that's a good way to
to turn your brain on and spot tactical
motives e4
is on the board all right let's let's
listen into jack to start he's got the
theater mode rocking
the screen
okay so what do we have why is it taking
so long on the first
move okay
oh gosh
no fried liver
solid very
basic opening so far dude i still don't
know
yeah dude i was just about to call that
out i still don't know what the best
play
here is dude this is where
i start getting tripped up for no good
reason
against force and deploy actually for no
good reason i just get tripped up here
so this becomes unprotected
but let's go
here he takes i think i take with bishop
i'm challenging both of these
it's not a bad move it's just because
he's not playing it because run to this
issue
all the time and i just panic and do the
wrong move
all the time i think this is okay
i think with bishop
it's fine
clearly he doesn't know what to do
either if it's taken him this long
clearly he's he's not the most
confident in the world either
true
whoa whoa
i can see why
and he'll take he's up a pawn already
which is
not what i want um but i can take his
pawn
monetizing our videos
[Laughter]
it's bound to happen
all right but okay seriously back to
this moment he played the same thing
against forsen and i asked him in the
interview if he
that was a line that he knew and he said
no i was just playing and now now i
understand more of his thought process
he's clearly
you know really overreacting to the
bishop even though 95 is not
a bad move nor is this position really
that bad right i mean
maybe there's some craziness hey carl
what's what's going on here
well i want to see if xcc moves the
queen here i think either queen e7 or
queen f6 are both good moves um
so i want to see if he plays one of
those moves i think the position is
pretty balanced so far
um but i expected i think it's very
likely we'll get a blunder really
quickly from one of the two players
this is a good move for mix you see
right here yeah i really like d5
accent move preventing the captures on
f7 and chasing the bishop away so it's a
tempo and a bishop b5 check he can
continue with b
if it's c6 well and now now either one
of hikaru's suggestions are even
stronger
now we're gonna see if xqc is putting
two and two together because queen e7
threatens this idea of moving the knight
with the discovery and the check on the
and the discover check where you hit the
king and then you win the queen
he's looking at queen e7 he's drawing it
on his board
let's go there let's go to there
i i think this is a mistake i have to
try though
okay let's see it let's see it
because if he moves knights i can do a
big fancy play here
[Music]
he does see the idea will he realize
that he can try to chase it away
he goes
oh he's in trouble i got in the headlock
hopefully i'm not here locking myself
[Laughter]
wait this could be insane
he actually sees he sees this he sees it
now there is five check to be clear but
i think that's a very hard move to see
here i could just block like this yeah
bing bang
[Music]
i go like this when you move this dude i
have a discovery check
[Music]
well he's done discovery check
it's working overnight here
here no here
no
[Music]
that's a broken man
wow that is a five head response to a
difficult situation by scissors
because these guys are finding
grandmaster moves
now king d8 is still probably very
strong
[Music]
an excuse is pointing between
66 immediately
okay they're still cleaning up seven i
can't go roll them
oh man
[Music]
what the am i doing i have a fork
here
[Music]
no i don't if i did i just gonna take it
check takes takes and then i go i go
i go negative score
good i need him to be lower on time so i
don't feel the time pressure i need him
to feel the time pressure
we're looking all right i think
like i said i feel like i've been
playing more chess and getting worse but
i feel like
i'm doubting myself that was a good move
right right
again now we're good
i really do want a castle soon though i
don't like
this going on here i don't i don't like
this
dude he's gotta move man what is he
doing dude
[Music]
is that good what a game what a game
i don't i don't
they're sick secretly titled players
is that i did not think of it i did not
think of this dude
oh man i know knight f4 is very good for
white but it's
not enough i did not foresee this dude
it's not an easy move to find
concrete oh
no okay
okay uh
okay
[Laughter]
now oh god i thought i was looking good
i feel like there's something really
good i can do
[Music]
but why am i not seeing it
go here no here no he just gets my queen
[Music]
he's gonna play it
oh he stopped too soon yeah i thought
you would go
i should be able to do here if i
take
[Music]
i can check
walk
i think i'm losing a knight here
[Music]
or a3 a3 is also oh i don't like this
i thought i liked this now i don't like
[Music]
this
oh my gosh guys what a game to start
with
this is correct let's explain why knight
f4 is an important move here
his knight is hanging on g6 yeah
or a3 also kicks the knight and the main
reason everybody's
tonight moves then d5 falls which
yeah i think a3 is very difficult to
find night for i would expect jack that
he is capable of finding it because he
was looking at all sorts of night moves
they're like going forward right and the
whole tactical idea is based around this
like this is like not a move that like
might be occurring right in his head he
and indeed backs up the queen wow
walks away from the tactic although okay
oh you guys
have three though he gets that three
next move
he's gonna say if you didn't see knight
f4 or a3 this is not the worst find by
jack right it shows his critical
thinking is really in order here he
finds a way to resourcefully get out of
it
wow both these guys even if they're not
finding absolute best ones are finding
some really really difficult
moves on on every turn so i'm very
impressed by both players so far
yeah and xqc is calculating queen takes
g6 queen b5
check he's read about the b4 knight that
one
true true that's a good point
he ultimately does take with the queen
good decision
because if this happens everyone c6
takes black gets queen takes g2 in the
end
this this would be a big problem
oh look at jack jack castles which again
from big picture point of view
safety first not the end of the world
for jack at least his king
is out of the way true true true true
bishop h3 would be very strong here this
rage 3 rook g would be very strong i
think
but again both players are low on time
as well like it's amazing we're on what
like move 10 or something
like move 12 or 13 and both players are
down like three and a half minutes which
is insane
h3 would be a five head move showing xqc
woke up on the right side of that blue
mattress let's go listen in
he's looking at it he's looking at it
just now
oh my god
wow definitely five heads
[Music]
[Laughter]
is
that's checkmates
[Music]
what else do you see i don't know
what else do you see i wonder what his
plan will be after f3 is
there has to be something i can do here
now one thing that i was thinking a
magic trick i can pull off and i know it
one thing that actually is not very good
at is
[Music]
bang bang bang
no no no no no
[Music]
he was even looking at bishop thank you
he saw that this is not mover
[Music]
i'm not making a up
he was highlighting it because because
the new board colors i i know i didn't
know i was
it
[Music]
i mean this is still decent i mean
i like this by the way i didn't mean
i was going to praise it but but he's
saying that because he changed the
settings like he doesn't realize when
it's just highlighting and writing move
i mean you can just take this for free
right oh no i don't know because
that's not me i mean it might be a good
this might be a great move if scissors
doesn't see the
fish and scissors hasn't done it which
makes me think he doesn't see it
all right let's go check in with him oh
let's go oh he just found it wow
and then take this we're good
it's back in the game
[Music]
i didn't choke
don't delete the vod not yet
[Music]
too hyper focused on what he's doing i'm
not even paying attention to where my
pieces are dude
i'm being an idiot
now get this too
you should take it
what are these arrows dude i don't want
these here stop it
okay how do i
attack him i don't want him to castle
right now i think queen
oh you can't clean his castle stop that
stop literally stop
don't move here
eliminates all the changes
he cannot cross
i can check him with this
he has 22 seconds dude he's got to go
he has 20 seconds holy
man
[Music]
okay
unfortunately
i can't let him think i just gotta go
what are you trying to get this maybe
i can check
[Music]
take this um
i can't check again i don't know if i
want to take this and get this
aggressive here
[Music]
that was and almost bought this gambit
with queen h6
a lot of things have happened since we
had our board up including
excuse me missing that his knight was
hanging on before
yeah i mean it smelled very okay now
there's checkmate yeah scissors
jack just
wild game really wild game
sqc started incredibly well he was
winning at the beginning of the game he
won a piece and had a great position
right yeah if he hadn't played knight g5
he probably he would have had good
chances but
i don't think he was ever clear for
either side until after that that
that um that that white was going to win
that game
yes um excuse is already checking by the
way the game report and where he went
wrong and he realizes that knight g5 is
a red
move that's where he right exactly yeah
yeah
you